Jimmy your guys are still leading 3-2
you have a home game to close it out
what's the sense after being up 3-0 then
losing two in a row by a combined 30
points in the locker room from you
what's the mindset now where the Siri
stands
we just got to play better start the
games off better on the starters make it
more difficult for them they're in the
Rhythm since the beginning of the game
but we're always going to stay positive
knowing that we can and we will win this
series and we'll just have to close it
out at home
Jimmy to follow up on that why is it
that
your confidence and the group's
confidence remains so high given the way
the last two games unfold because the
last two games are not who we are it
just happened to be that way and we
stopped playing defense
halfway because we didn't make shots
that we want to make but that's easy
correct we just gotta come out and play
harder from jump so like I always say
um it's gonna be all smiles we're gonna
keep it very very very consistent
knowing that we are going to win the
next game
Jimmy we've been talking a little bit in
here about how they've made it harder on
bam what does it look like to you that
the Celtics have changed defensively
uh I mean I think they pack the paint
really well switching really well and
just contesting shots without fouling at
that
I think that's the that's the game as a
whole but it's on us to get him in
better positions to score the ball get
it to him in transition stuff like that
you know when you look at the film and
you look at how we can be better and get
him in into his spots with the ball
um in a position and with the time on
the clock to score we'll be better at
that
obviously you miss Gabe and he's
important and now there's no Gabe
there's no Tyler there's no Vic other
guys did step up and give contributions
Haywood uh Duncan
is there a comfort in knowing that there
are other guys there and that they were
able to step for you and there's other
numbers and guys to call upon if needed
yeah without a doubt guys are so
confident because they've been in this
position
all year long with with guys in and out
of the lineup they're constantly working
on their game so they don't switch up
anything just because you know it's game
five of the playoffs or game five of the
Season they're gonna do what they're
comfortable with they're going to do
whatever you ask for them to do and um
they're gonna play well like I feel like
they did in the um possessions in the
time that they got out there